the theme of this inaugural week is
creating tomorrow and this morning we
will explore that theme in the form of a
debate on the topic of the future of
conservative and liberal ideology which
is the best guide into the 21st century
this seems an appropriate debate topic
for us so close here to the Mississippi
River with its many tributaries and a
river so prominent in our history
including a key phrase in the university
alma mater perhaps we should think about
the early explorers of America's rivers
and try to imagine what it must have
been like for them as they moved against
the current pausing frequently to
determine if they should follow the
right or the left tributary the great
explorers Lewis and Clark who met in
Louisville Kentucky to launch their
great expedition to the west may in fact
have stopped to near present-day Cape
Girardeau to consider their future
course on this significant day in the
history of Southeast Missouri State
University in cape girardeau let us
pause to consider directions as we seek
to create the course to tomorrow if we
are fortunate in that this morning we
have with us two of the most well known
explorers of conservative and liberal
ideology in the nation senator George
McGovern has for the past
quarter-century been identified with
liberal causes and New Directions in
American politics a two-term member of
the House of Representatives at a US
Senator for 18 years
senator McGovern was the 1972 Democratic
presidential nominee mr. McGovern grew
up in a small town in South Dakota where
his father was a Methodist minister
World War two broadened his horizons
beyond the prairies as he served as a
pilot of the Dakota Queen a b-24 bomber
in which he flew 35 missions and for
which he earned the
Distinguished Flying Cross he returned
home after the war and did graduate work
in American history earning a PhD at
Northwestern University and returned to
South Dakota to become a college history
professor in 1962 he was elected to the
US Senate where he became one of the
first members of the US Congress to
openly oppose American participation in
the Vietnam War mr. McGovern served on
the Senate Foreign Relations Committee
throughout the 1970s and was appointed
by both presidents Carter and Ford as a
United Nations delegate in 1982 he
founded Americans for common-sense
providing an alternative political voice
on behalf of minorities the poor and
other marginalized Americans Senator
McGovern is the author of four books
agricultural fought in the 20th century
a time of War II time of peace is
autobiography grass roots and more
recently Terry a deeply moving chronicle
of his third child's efforts to overcome
her addiction to alcohol senator
McGovern has previously been on our
campus and I would like for you to join
with me and welcome him back to
Southeast Missouri State University
William F Buckley is a nationally
prominent author columnist politician
editor adventurer philosopher lecturer
and television personality and the list
goes on
in 1955 mr. Buckley founded the
conservative journal National Review
which is today the Journal of opinion
with the largest circulation in America
in 1962 he began his syndicated column
on the right today it appears twice a
week in over 300 newspapers here and
abroad in 1966 mr. Buckley began hosting
his weekly television show firing line
which is now the longest-running
television program in the United States
with the same host virtually every
political and intellectual leader
throughout the world has been a guest on
the show is won an Emmy Award for
program achievement and the TV Guide
Award for the best television
interviewer in America as an author his
diversity holds no bounds mr. Buckley is
philosophical in God and man at Yale up
from liberalism and right reason is
autobiographical in overdrive and the
unmaking of a mirror it's written a
great number of fictional works plays
and even children's books weymouth
Buckley was born in New York City
graduated with honors from Yale and has
been awarded over 35 honorary degrees in
1991 he was the recipient of the
Presidential Medal of Freedom
please welcome to our campus for the
first time mr. William F Buckley
procedures for the debate will be as
follows mr. Buckley will lead off with
15 minutes allotted for him to outline
his views on the question of which is
the best guidance for the 21st century
conservative or liberal ideology mr.
McGovern will then follow with 15
minutes to rebut mr. Buckley and then
deliver his own thoughts on the topic
mr. Buckley will then have five minutes
to rebut mr. McGovern and following
these comments from our two
distinguished visitors we will have
questions from a panel consisting of two
students two faculty members and two
members from the Cape Girardeau
Community these individuals I'd like to
introduce now our neil e boyd vice
president of student government here at
southeast miss Christy Johnson a student
representative also to the southeast
Board of Regents of mr. Howard Michael
who is the general manager of AFVs
television in Cape Girardeau miss Anne
Poston Human Resources of the Dana
corporation and dr. Alberta Dugan
chairman of the Department of History at
southeast and dr. Peter Bergersen
chairman of the department of political
science here
following questions from the panel mr.
Buckley and mr. McGovern will have
approximately three to five minutes to
make their closing remarks we're very
pleased to have here this morning c-span
with us to film to today's program we
look forward to the opportunity to view
our session on their American
perspectives program and now if we can
initiate our debate I would like to
introduce to you mr. William F Buckley
oh thank you ladies and gentlemen
members members of the panel mr.
chairman senator McGovern I'm they're
happy to be here in to participate in
the August events of the of the day I
thank you all for the hospitality
extended thus far and it is true that
yesterday driving in senator McGovern
expressed his disappointment that he was
not being asked to read his poetry at
the inauguration I told him what he
would be doing the debate is reciting
political poetry fun to listen to but
not anything to be guided by the central
government has had a distinguished
history and the American Century
is very beholden to him especially
beholden to him for not having been
elected
we've been asked to suggest suggest
guidance on into the 21st century and
asked whether in the course of the 20th
century we have been primarily owned by
developments that tend us in
conservative positions or tendus in
liberal positions I think it important
to reflect in foreign policy that it has
been a very sad century we've had great
climactic victories but at a very high
cost I was 18 years old when the bomb at
Hiroshima went off and I was a senior
citizen when the Berlin Wall came down
the interval was called called V the
Cold War it's quite true that we won the
Cold War but it's also true that an
entire generation began young and ended
old before that war was one that was
substantially the result of our failure
to do the right thing at the right time
the object of statecraft is to abort
crisis it can be said that we aborted
crises in the sense that we did not end
the century in a great nuclear blast
that consumed the planet it can't be
said that we won the Cold War in the
sense of relieving millions upon
millions upon millions of people of the
terrible lives that their entire it
would take that took up their entire
lifetimes these were opportunities
missed and opportunities that continue
to be missed and we were time to ask are
there guidelines that distinguish
conservative statecraft from the state
statecraft commonly thought of as as
liberal
a paradoxically enough mr. McGovern is
not in the hard liberal tradition of his
own party the notion that we can and
must be responsible for spreading
democracy everywhere was most
emphatically popularized in this century
by Woodrow Wilson as we all know and re
emphasized by John F Kennedy in his
inaugural address back in nineteen back
in 1824 an appetite developed in America
to intervene in the war of Austrian
succession it was on that occasion that
President John Adams gave his celebrated
speech on the 4th of July in which he
said American people are friends of
Liberty everywhere but custodians only
of their own that foresight tempered the
expanse of suggestion that we should
send the Marines to every corner of the
world in which practices were not
identical to our own we had a sense of
the limitations of power which sense we
exercised attempting to make irrelevant
distinctions this was highlighted when
we sent Marines in 1965 to land in the
Dominican Republic the Dominican
Republic occupies the East and half of a
single island at East paniolo on the
right
on the eastern half where we did land
the Marines a threat was acknowledged of
a Soviet salient similar to Cuba's I in
anticipation of such an effort we did
land the Marines air and we tended to
reorient the situation away from that
possibility as 10 years later we didn't
Grenada
well the western half of the same island
rained papa doc one of the singular
sadists of this century which there is
much competition we ignored him
substantially ignored him because he
wasn't a part of an apparatus that
sought the destruction of Liberty
everywhere that was a kind of a
geopolitical distinction very
satisfactory to conservative
reconnaissance and one which I would
urge on you to pass along to the 21st
century after I am no longer there to
counsel it
these are distinctions that I urge on
the country and these are in very sharp
departure from the consistent calls for
disarmament that have characterized
senator McGovern's public career at one
point when Don F Kennedy was a president
he called for one disarmament Drive
which was rejected by the Senate by a
vote of 76 to 2
I slit engraving as a policy maker where
in my judgment he belongs be isolated
miss mr. McGovern in his lust for peace
found himself backing Henry Wallace
associates two to nineteen hundred and
forty-eight and now mr. McGovern is
identified with that inscrutable or
movement that says that we should not
spend money to develop an anti-missile
missile this this refusal to exploit our
own technological resources given the
fact that we live in an age in which
more and more countries have a the
nuclear have have chemical and nuclear
and biological means of spreading
massive destruction is an economy that
is that is a a very difficult to
understand so we won't we want a
combination of a Provident use of
American resources together with a
a convincing an emphatic power to have
our way when when as custodians of the
balance of freedom in the world our
efforts become critical unhappily
senator McGovern also has views on
domestic policy those views on domestic
policy can be summarized by his
enthusiasm for turning problems on over
to the shoulders of the state it's
remarkable how how reluctant we ought to
learn about the impoverishment of
handing over social ideals to to the
government it was it was the amount
Dames um no he was Jefferson who said
the government can only do something for
you
in proportion as it can do something to
you and it was up and it was Adams who
said the government turns every
contingency into an excuse for amassing
greater power in its own hands Woodrow
Wilson said the history of liberalism is
a history of man's efforts to restrain
the growth of government but have we
done anything of the sort there was a
great debate on the welfare bill last
year you may remember senator Kennedy
during that debate asked had we
forgotten what we have accomplished with
our welfare programs or what have we in
fact accomplished or with them since
1960 we spent two point six trillion
dollars on on welfare things on here
their little barren things I hear a
little bit worsens things here there are
really quite a lot were since 1960
there's been a 560 percent increase in
violent crime more than a 400% increase
in illegitimate births a quadrupling of
divorce rates a tripling of the
percentage of children living in
single-parent homes and a drop of 80
points in SAT manifestly there has been
a correlation between federal
disbursements on the general welfare but
it has been a negative
let's advise the 21st century to abide
by the principle of subsidiarity the
principle of subsidiarity says if there
is a problem turn it over to the private
sector to cope with if manifested can't
cope with it then turn it over to
government but always seek out the
lowest echelon of government not the
higher echelon of government it is the
tendency of liberalism instantly to be
attracted by total power the federal
government the power above all to tax
and the power to pass regulations and to
pass laws are the failure of the federal
government to solve the poverty program
is wonderfully manifested by the stark
figures in the year 1990 percent of the
American people were poor by current
standards of poverty that figure
diminished to eleven twelve thirteen
percent thirty years ago and it has not
moved substantially from there surely
one of the reasons why it has not moved
is because they have been so many
inhibitions on the kind of American
ingenuity and the American resources and
Americans passion to solve and to attack
social problems using those resources I
urge you therefore to pass along to the
21st century the wonderful intuition of
Alfred North Whitehead the philosopher
he said you know you learned much more
in the study of history about any
situation about any era by examining
what it is the people aren't saying what
the arts saying is what they take for
granted what we are ceasing increasingly
to say in America is the extent of which
there is a correlation between how much
money is spent by the public sector over
against how much money is spent by the
private sector spending by the private
sector is money spent in the exercise of
individual freedom
the moment is taken by the public sector
this transmuted into an anonymous a
collectivity which seeks to affect goals
that appeal to foreign legislators
sitting in Washington and squandering
our resources if you want to interrupt
me with a burst of applause I will
understand your brother didn't tell you
that
I invite a Senator McGovern to rewrite
history he is well equipped academically
to do that and I think that send him to
Washington was a terrible loss to the
Academy and we should all grieve
senator McGovern will now make his
statement of philosophy looking into the
21st century
mecco
members of the panel my friend William
Buckley let me say first of all that I'm
pleased to be on this campus of
Southeast Missouri State University and
especially in view of a longtime
friendship I have had with your
president Dale mitts key it's been my
privilege since leaving the Senate some
16 years ago to be on campuses all
across this country
and I know of no president that I rate
above Dale Mitch gate I think you're
very fortunate to
as professor met michael has told us
William Buckley is a very distinguished
novelist it's been my been my it's been
my privilege and my gain to read most of
those novels and I commend all of them
they're very well done and will hold
your attention the chairman has also
reminded you that I'm a historian so mr.
Buckley and I have reached an agreement
about this debate today as a novelist he
will give you nothing but fiction and
you've already had a sample of that and
as a historian I will give you nothing
but the truth today
I'm going to say most of my rebuttal and
totally time for the rebuttal in the
debate I'm supposed to give my
constructive speech on liberalism at
this point but let me just say I have
noted my esteemed sparring partner mr.
Buckley has this morning as he has in
other debates quoted with some approval
such Liberal Democrats as Woodrow Wilson
and John Kennedy on other occasions he's
even quoted Harry Truman and Franklin
Roosevelt but what I have noted about
all of these cases is that in addition
to being very distinguished liberals
they're also all now dead and I I once
said to Bill if I promise to die before
you do will you say a few good things
about me
he was non-committal I just want to make
one comment at the outset here about my
position on disarmament which has been
referred to here today and also a
mention that I had once supported the
former vice president the United States
former Secretary of Agriculture Henry
Wallace when world war ii came along
Pearl Harbor I was a sophomore at Dakota
Wesleyan University I was 19 years of
age and I volunteered within three
months to serve as a bomber pilot in
that war what I discovered is that there
were no instructors trained there were
no airplanes available for training
purposes when I say no I mean grossly
inadequate even not enough training
fields I had to wait for a year before
they could take us into service because
of that lack of preparedness I never
again want to see the United States in
that position I have always been without
fail for a strong national defense for
the United States this has been a
dangerous world all of my life and I've
always supported a strong national
defense but that did not include backing
the policy makers who thought it was in
the interest of our defence and security
to send our young men to Vietnam even
the architects
even the architects of that mistaken
policy now know that it was a dreadful
mistake if you don't believe that take
the time to read Robert McNamara's
memoir one of the chief architects and
most consistent advocates of our
involvement there are those of us who
criticized American policy there are
sometimes branded as weak on defense
those of us who criticize unnecessary
and wasteful military spending that we
know something about based on our own
service are also sometimes criticized as
weak on national defense those critics
were led by the one five-star general
we've had in the White House President
Eisenhower who warned in his farewell
address that a major problem before this
country was the mounting power of the
military-industrial complex and its
capacity to get its way at times when it
went beyond the real defense and
security requirements of the country so
I don't need a lecture on weakness or on
national defense but I do want to make
clear that one of the challenges to both
liberals and conservatives as to as we
move into this next century is to
recognize that the Cold War has ended
we've built up a massive military
structure around the world that was
designed to fight a war simultaneously
against the Soviet Union and Communist
China now the Soviet Union is gone and
China has become our most favored nation
trading partner so we need to look at
this massive spending for military
purposes and ask ourselves whether we
need all of that money to continue going
in that direction or whether some of it
should be diverted to rebuilding other
sources of national strength such as our
roadways our bridges our tunnels
our water and sewage systems and other
things that this country needs that also
contribute to national defense and
national security and one of the reasons
I support the liberal tradition although
frequently some of my fellow liberals
have not stood up on this issue as well
as I wish they had is that I think we
have a better chance of leading this
country into a balanced view of how we
allocate our resources in the 21st
century let me just add one further
thing I never once in all of those 10
years of trying to stop our involvement
in Vietnam ever criticized one American
soldier those soldiers had my full
sympathy and understanding and support
and they still do I can't look at that
wall the Vietnam Wall in Washington with
those 58,000 names without a sense of
real grief I mourn the passing of every
one of those boys but it was the
policymakers who needed to be challenged
and that's what we're talking about here
today now the question that that mr.
Buckley and I were originally given was
the future of conservative and liberal
ideology will they survive into the 21st
century I I take the view that I
earnestly hope both of these time-tested
political traditions will survive into
the 20th century I want to see both
William F Buckley and George McGovern
make it into the 21st century and
and I hope that the traditions the rival
traditions that we represent will
continue to flourish because it's been
my conviction for a long time that it is
the the creative tension and the the
competition if you will of ideas between
conservatism on one hand and liberalism
on the other that is the real genius of
American politics this is the source of
much of our strength and it's the reason
that John Adams and Thomas Jefferson won
a liberal one a conservative went to
their graves admiring each other with
affection and approval despite their
competing views I want as I say the
conservative tradition to be heard and I
want to Bill Buckley to continue to be
heard but I don't want him to go
unchallenged
any more than I think that liberalism
and George McGovern should go
unchallenged my mother and father were
lifelong conservative lifelong
Republicans religious fundamentalist I
was too until World War two came along
and I traveled around the the world for
a while and then came back to
Northwestern University and under the GI
Bill of Rights one of these awful
federal programs that mr. Buckley thinks
concentrates too much power in the hands
of the federal government under that
program I and several million other
Americans were educated that program
cost billions of dollars but we're told
that having educated a whole generation
of young Americans it more than paid for
itself the Fed
government actually made money on it the
taxpayers made money on it why because
those young men and some women were able
to increase their earning power to the
point where they more than paid back the
cost of that investment and they lifted
the quality of American society from
that day to this it's a Marvis marvelous
example of what a liberal program
originally opposed by conservatives can
do to move this country forward even
prior to that I saw the record of
liberalism as a high school a student
growing up out in the Dust Bowl days in
in South Dakota South Dakota is now
underwater but when I was growing up it
was afflicted with dust storms and
droughts chronically farmers were going
broke the banks had failed people were
out of work it was a desperate place
I don't recall being particularly poor I
guess because everybody was poor
certainly Methodist ministers were poor
in those days and I grew up in a
parsonage but what I saw was a positive
series of moves by the federal
government some of them were clumsy some
of them could have been better but they
did things like bringing electricity to
the farms of South Dakota the REA
program they developed the Tennessee
Valley Authority the Missouri River and
other river systems they put unemployed
people to work in the Civilian
Conservation camps they provided
guaranteed bank deposits so the banks
could open again with the confidence of
their customers they provided social
security for our grandparents they
provided work for people building
courthouses and roadways and shelter
bells and all the rest and that was the
record of liberalism in the period
when I was growing up in South Dakota in
a Republican Party in a Republican
family but it began to set my own mind
thinking about Franklin Roosevelt and
later Harry Truman and then in the
decade that followed World War two we
saw not only things like the GI Bill of
Rights we saw the beginning of civil
rights
we saw shortly after that movements to
build the interstate highway system
again the long arm of the federal
government that mr. Buckley spoke about
and we saw a whole range of other
programs including movements to provide
equality for women the environmental
movement the effort to lift the quality
of education this is the liberal agenda
I regret to say that that agenda has
sometimes made the most comfortable and
most entrenched of our citizens a little
nervous why because you can't do
positive things like the GI Bill of
Rights and Rea and public service jobs
when people are unemployed without taxes
it's true there is no such thing as a
free lunch somebody has to pay for these
things and there are some people so
comfortable in their own resources they
can't understand that there are other
needs across this country that do
require public expenditure and so
there's been a ceaseless barrage against
the whole concept of liberalism over the
last 20 years I regret to say that many
of my fellow liberals instead of
standing up to that barrage have run for
cover and have chosen to march under a
different banner I'm still a proud
liberal I believe that this liberal
agenda is endorsed by most Americans I
honestly believe that most American
liberals even though many of them are
unaware of what the liberal agenda is if
they understood that it embraced Social
Security and Medicare and the
environmental program and civil rights
and the effort to end the war in Vietnam
and all of these other things that I've
talked about here today I think most
Americans would say that while we need a
strong conservative tradition to
challenge and check and criticize these
liberal initiatives I think they would
also recognize that it is the liberal
tradition that has given us most of the
forward progress in our society let me
put it to you this way I can't think of
a single public program now generally
endorsed by most Americans all the way
from Ronald Reagan to the Reverend Jesse
Jackson that did not begin as a liberal
initiative over conservative opposition
that doesn't mean conservatives are bad
they need to raise criticisms about some
of these government initiatives and how
they're run it does mean that we've had
to depend on the liberal impulse for
most of the gains we've made in modern
times I think the same will be true in
the 21st century when we have other
problems that need to be addressed and
I've already mentioned one the need to
accept the post Cold War period and
begin to convert carefully some of the
unnecessary arms outlays to the
rebuilding of this great country thank
you so much
you
mr. Buckley will now present a
five-minute rebuttal
well senator McGovern says he doesn't
need a lecture on defense
after all the Cold War is over in 1967
he wanted to be voted against the ABM
financing in 1969 he said that
negotiating from strength is one of most
damaging and costly cliches the American
vocabulary in 1970 he wanted to get out
of NATO he want to start the ABM and he
Merv and the AMSA conventions 1971 he
said about ABN he thought it temporarily
at any event it should be halted even
unilaterally in 18 1971 he want to cut
50% off the defense budget that was
during the days of the Cold War now
these are simply his Pacific impulses
they have to do with them I think he a
quite general misunderstanding about how
it is that the things get accomplished
what needed to be accomplished during
the Cold War was to win it not win it
yet have a preponderance of strength in
order to have a preponderance of
strength we had financed a defense
industry the notion that all of that is
happening that we approve of is somehow
a financed by the wispy creation of
money somewhere I is of course the great
delusion if modern liberalism
what was it in 1873 that caused the
founding of this college it was not any
act of Washington DC of any importance
what was it that caused the huge engine
that slowly wiped away poverty for 90%
of the American people it wasn't
anything done by Washington it was
things done by people like Edison and bi
and Ford and millions and millions of
other entrepreneurs the whole notion
that we should be grateful to the
government for good health of a good
education
belies the central point if I'm going to
school and I'm not paying for it
somebody else is paying for it who is
that person if I'm up getting medical
care and I'm not paying what somebody
else is paying for it the notion of the
mysteriously accumulating a dollar in
Washington DC is the principal
hallucination fostered by contemporary
American liberalism in fact as in the
case of Missouri one half of one percent
more money is spent from Washington to
this state than the other way around you
are financing your own ventures for all
intents and purposes and money this
sentence to Washington go to Wharton
comes back here spends an expensive
night out on the town in Washington and
there was an attrition in that dollar
that is returned to you it is necessary
in exploring the notion of what we learn
from one another to engage the idea of
progress the traditional method
philosophically and scientifically is a
thesis antithesis but then comes
synthesis I certainly would expect for
the rest of my lifetime to learn from
George McGovern and indeed from other
liberals but I am asking for a rejection
of that which we have learned does not
work what is the answer into the
crowning American problem of the day
which is basically there's a legitimacy
for everyone every audit of a child you
have a 600% statistical increase in
crime and poverty and dope addiction
what is it that liberalism tells us
about Newton we see only the we can't
pray in schools I think that's most
creative thing that they have ever come
up with on this particular subject so
that liberalism refuses to accost
genuine reality preferring instead
simply to cite free electricity in South
Dakota or 50 years ago it wasn't free
electricity somebody had to pay for it
I'm delighted they had electricity there
though maybe if George McGovern as a
child had read one fewer
you might have enlightened us more
senator McGovern will now have five
minutes for his rebuttal
let me just pick up again on this point
on the votes on the arms budget because
I think that is important every American
wants this country to be adequately
defended no one is advocating that we
strip our defenses to the point where
we're unable to protect American
security it's true some of these items
that that my friend mr. Buckley has
mentioned did have me in opposition I
was opposed to the ABM we find that's
the anti-ballistic missile system as it
stood then it was widely assailed by
some of the best defense experts in the
country as a mistake we finally agreed
to build one of them in North Dakota if
you want to see the biggest white
elephant in the American defense arsenal
sometime when you're in North Dakota
asked to visit the ABM which is up there
collecting dust and moss which provides
nothing in the way of real defense for
this country but which cost us six
billion dollars for that failed
experiment I have always believed that
the best way to defend ourselves against
nuclear attack is the route that most of
our presidents have taken which is to
negotiate arms reduction agreements with
the former Soviet Union rather than
starting a second arms race as to who
can build the greatest defensive system
against the others met others missiles
all that does is to trigger the other
country and to increase their offensive
missiles you never win on that
proposition and I think we finally come
to discover that I might add that if you
had to identify the principal causes for
the collapse of the Soviet Union why
this system fell in addition to the fact
that Soviet Communism was simply a lousy
system
it was made even lousy er by the fact
that the Russians were spending so much
of their resources in this arms race
with the United States tens of thousands
of strategic weapons of all kinds that
they now love to find some way to get
rid of and I do not want to see the
United States go that route we're a much
wealthier country we can afford an arms
race like that better than the Soviets
and that's one of the reasons why they
went down and we a triumph but we don't
need to automatically continue this arms
accumulation into the future at a time
when no really significant military
power is challenging us anywhere in the
world we defeated the Iraqi army in a
few days with the commitment of 17% of
our armed force Armed Forces just now
it's hard to see anybody else that
presents any greater threat to the
United States so I think we need to keep
those things income in mind with regard
to George McGovern having cast a vote at
one time to reduce the military budget
incidentally the amount I was proposing
was a 2% reduction in military outlays
at a time when the defense budget was a
hundred billion dollars it's true that
vote came out 76 to 2 that doesn't
necessarily mean that two people were
wrong and 76 were right it could be the
other way around
did you ever think of that on the Gulf
of Tonkin Resolution in 1964 that
President Johnson presented to the
Senate in effect giving him a blank
check to escalate the war in Vietnam I
went along with that resolution so did
98 senators the vote was 98 to 2 in
support of that resolution only senator
Morris of Oregon and senator greening of
Alaska
had the wisdom and the courage to stand
up against it they were right the other
ninety eight of us were wrong on that
vote I'm not embarrassed about the votes
in the Senate where I stood alone or
with two or three other people the ones
that embarrass me are the ones where I
sometimes went along with the crowd when
I should have stood firm and
with regard to mr. Buckley's others
central argument here that these
domestic programs that I talked about
are fine but they cost money and they
run up debts and deficits I simply want
to say this I suppose if I were to pull
out mr. Buckley's heroes
politically they would not really be
Woodrow Wilson and Franklin Roosevelt or
John Kennedy or Harry Truman they'd more
likely be Ronald Reagan you know what
happened to federal spending and deficit
financing and the national debt during
those eight Reagan years it tripled the
national debt the biggest annual
deficits in our two hundred year history
the biggest national debt I recognized
the Congress went along with that and it
was a Democratic Congress much of that
time they could have blocked that but
even if they had accepted the Reagan
budget just the way it was submitted
every year that budget that was being
offered would have tripled the national
debt as indeed it did I'm not for that
kind of reckless deficit spending and I
think that very few Americans if they
stopped to think about it are so I don't
want to transfer so many obligations to
the federal government that we have to
run deficits and debts at that level I
do believe in fiscal integrity and I
think that's a mark of a responsible
liberal
we will now turn to our panel for
questions beginning with mr. Neil Boyd
mr. Boyd is a speech communication major
from Sikeston Missouri and Vice
President of Student Government mr. Boyd
again I would like to say thank you for
coming mr. Buckley senator McGovern
being a student involved in politics and
at an age where my own political
ideology is being shaped by researching
candidates issues and listening to
various amounts of a political rhetoric
my question is at what point in your own
lives did you begin developing your
conservative lip and liberal beliefs and
what role do you see for politically
active youth in shaping or reforming
modern political thought for generations
to come
good well I I never was a liberal I
guess I just done should acknowledge and
grace as a the lucky provider in my case
well I can't say that I was not a
conservative because I was I was reared
that way in South Dakota and by my
devout parents whom I admired then I
admire them even more after all these
years they gave me a moral underpinning
that I think has been the greatest
strength of anything I've had to offer
in public life but I began to hear those
liberal impulses during the Depression
in South Dakota I saw people really
suffering it wasn't because they didn't
work I saw farmers at work from dawn
until dusk who were going broke and
bankers and small businesspeople who
were working from dawn until dusk who
were going broke and we really had to do
something South Dakota voted Democratic
a couple of times in those years I think
my parents voted Republican but I began
to see things happening in that state
that I thought were in the interest of
everybody I have to confess to you my
light White has a letter that I sent her
from Italy during world war two in which
I was telling her why she should vote
for Dewey instead of Roosevelt so at
least through 1944 I guess you'd have to
classify me as a conservative but those
years at Northwestern and grad
school studying American history turned
me around we used to have an old
Republican neighbor mrs. Truex very dear
friend of our family she always said
that George got off the track when he
went to that big college in Chicago and
I suppose that's true from the
perspective of securities that's where I
began to move in a more liberal
direction to which I've held more or
less from that day to this I am the
second part of the question that has me
saying that I still believe in American
politics I still think it's an
honourable of profession and I would
encourage the best young people here to
think about it as a possible career will
now have a question from dr. Peter
Bergesen chairman of the Department of
Political Science good morning my
question is how do your respective
political ideologies give us a guide to
a peace settlement in the Middle East
particularly presently with the Israeli
and Palestinians Senator McGovern
well I've headed the Middle East Policy
Council it's a non-profit educational
group for the last five or six years I
used to be chairman of the Senate
Subcommittee on the Middle East so I've
been interested in that area for a long
time I have always felt that the long
term solution to the Middle East crisis
depends on a settlement of the
Palestinian question first the
Palestinians have long wanted an
independent entity or homeland to their
own it's difficult for me to understand
why so many Israelis who also want an
independent homeland and love their
country very dearly understandably why
they have so much difficulty
understanding that impulse on the part
of Palestinians I think if there's the
a settlement there there has to be a
certain amount of tolerance and humanity
on both sides there's no place for
terrorism in any of this and there's no
place for the kind of rigidity and
unyielding stubbornness that we
sometimes see on both sides I'm
especially concerned about Netanyahu
Prime Minister Netanyahu I wish with all
my heart that Shimon Peres had won the
Israeli election yeah I think I think
that's the view of most American Jewish
citizens as well as my view because I
think had that happen the Oslo agreement
could have been implemented there would
have been more concessions on territory
on boundaries on settlements on the
future status of Jerusalem all those
things are going to have to happen if
there's going to be peace in the Middle
East and it may very well be that our
own President and Secretary of State are
going to have to stand a little firmer
on insisting on concessions on the part
of all the parties if this peace process
is to move ahead Toto come in the second
student member of our panel is miss
Kristi Johnson from cooter Missouri an
accounting major and the Student
Representative to the University Board
of Regents miss Johnson
thank both of you for being here with us
this morning senator McGovern mentioned
earlier the GI on the GI Bill which
allowed him to obtain an education and I
think that the need for education is
evident in every mind however there are
clear differences in the way
conservatives and liberals view exactly
to what extent the public is responsible
for educating its citizens and exactly
how and in that light my question is how
important will higher education be to
the 21st century and is it
government's responsibility to ensure
that each citizen has the opportunity to
obtain a four-year college degree was
that yours well the answer's no I don't
think it's the government responsibility
to insist from the people and go to
school up to a certain point we accept
that 15 16 years old whatever it is and
but the even though it's statistically
provable that in most cases people
generate more money about 30 percent
more if they go to college Military
College
we still our society that our honors the
right in the people to go there their
own way the notion that dump that people
necessarily ought to go to college is
one of those great wonderful enduring
American superstitions as things stand
right now 25 set of people
this is biggest as of two years ago who
matriculated in college do not go on to
sophomore year and fifty percent of
those who matriculated colors do not
graduate
now this isn't necessary because they
run out of money it may be because they
run into academic problems that they
can't handle or it may be that they get
married and do other things watch limbo
as his mother was telling me a moment
ago made it only through one class here
go over dolla never went to our college
he does all right it's it's a it's we
really should do away with the
superstition that unless you go to
college you I you are in some any sense
I'm way contemptible it's wonderful to
go to college and people make wonderful
sacrifices to make it possible but there
ought to be a suggestion that admission
to
hi sanctuaries American life are only
for those who have gone to college they
should be welcome in whatever enterprise
they they undertake
I agree with a considerable amount of
what mr. Buckley has just said I think a
college education is desirable for for
most young people there's some we're
probably better suited to go in a
different direction it's my own further
feeling that given the crisis in our
budget right now we can't afford to
underwrite a free four-year education
for everyone I think it's it's not in
the cards right now in terms of the
fiscal condition of the country even if
it were desirable it's not within our
our reach having said earlier though
that the GI is educated after World War
two and of course there weren't nearly
as many of them as there are people who
might like to go to college today more
than paid for their education I think
that's a strong case for strengthening
the student loan program that we've now
had on the statute books for many years
instead of cutting back on that program
I think the president is right and
stressing that we are strengthen it
those loans in my opinion are pretty
good risk it does put a burden on young
people after they graduate but that
education is also given them tools that
according to all the statistics enable
them to earn more and therefore to gain
the capacity to retires that's loans so
that's the direction in which I would go
to make sure that we have a strong
guaranteed loan program and make it as
widely available as practical
the next question will be posed by Miss
tan Poston who works in the area of
human resources with the Dana
corporation my question is regarding
health care with healthcare costs
becoming an increasingly larger
percentage of the GNP each year what
changes do you foresee in healthcare in
the future and what if any role do you
see the government playing in bringing
those changes about well we knew we had
to do something about the galloping cost
of healthcare a straight extrapolation
of its growth during the first five
years of this decade would have shown it
in the year - OH - one is consuming 100%
of the national product so it had to
begin to dip and it has this last year
it increased by 2.2 percent with
inflation increasing by 2.3 percent that
narrowly edged out inflation however
it's caused a lot of dissatisfaction the
healthcare program is as somebody
remotely in its adolescence there are
all kinds of dissatisfactions talk law
doctors are unhappy very interesting and
good reasons our patients are unhappy
inevitably inevitably one has to go in
the direction of deductibility the the
person who is uh who is uh mischievously
and the voluptuously a health minded can
use up an awful lot of money that need
not necessarily be spent and they're
very they're very few market enticements
or have been to do the right thing
somebody point out a year and a half ago
if you wanted a blood test in Houston
you could go to eight different places
and get it for prices ranging with $15
to $84 it was zero zero sanctioned to go
to $15 place rather than $82 place on
the majority of insurance policies
something that works in the marketplace
principal has got to be admitted in
remember whispering 13% of our gross
national product on health the the the
Brits with their socialized system of
spending eight Canadians with a
socialized system of spending 8.2 so
that we are wildly extravagant even by
the terms of state-run industries I
think one of the encouraging trends in
American health these days is that more
and more Americans are becoming health
conscious and are taking the kind of
preventive steps that will keep them
healthy I think there needs to be more
that more of an emphasis both in
American medical practice and also on
the part of all of us of individuals of
doing certain common-sense things that
keep us from getting sick I'm talking
about watching the diet I'm talking
about watching the alcohol and nicotine
intake I'm talking about exercise Bill
Buckley works as hard as anybody I know
he's one of the hardest-working human
beings in this country but I noticed
that he's always got his weight under
control he goes out and exercises every
day he watches his diet with some
measure of a common sense and this is
what all of us have to do if we want to
live long happy healthy lives
now beyond that sometimes we're going to
get sick no matter how much emphasis we
put on prevention I hope those
prevention efforts can begin right down
at the kindergarten level with our
children where we teach prevention and
common-sense health measures but there
are probably thirty five million
Americans in this country who have no
health insurance and when they get sick
they're in trouble they don't have
enough income to pay the premiums there
are other middle-income people who are
finding it increasingly hard
to pay these escalating hospital and
medical costs and we have to do
something about that
this may seem unrealistic given the
present political climate in the country
but I still believe that comprehensive
national health insurance is the way to
go where I think it would be better for
the doctors I think it would be better
for the hospital's the nurses and I
think it would be better for the
patients I would insist under any such
system that people have a right to
choose their own doctor and their own
the medical care but I do think that as
the only industrialized country in the
world that does not have a system of
comprehensive national health care that
as we move into the 21st century that
ought to be high on the list of goals
for this country I don't believe this
managed care system is going to work
very well I heard a story the other day
about three people that arrived at the
pearly gates at the same time a doctor
who told st. Peter he'd always
ministered to the health of his patients
st. Peter said go into eternal life and
enjoy it a nurse comes along makes the
same claim to go into the pearly gates
and joy your eternal life the next
person said I'm the director of a
managed care program he said go in
through the pearly gates and stay for
three days this
this is one of the this is one of the
problems with managed-care there's too
much of the bottom line profit making
for those who manage those systems and
not enough concern about the well-being
the patient I'm for national health
insurance we will now turn to mr. Howard
Michael the general manager of ke FES
television I'm the light beer today I'm
curious as to your opinions on the
campaign process as it is today and is
it the best process in your mind for
going into the new millennium it seems
to have degraded to sniping rather than
skewing issues and being elected by
tearing down your opponent I wonder if I
would be interested in your opinions on
how or what should be done to change it
bill is deferring to me as a
practitioner of politics one time or
will he he waged a valiant campaign for
mayor New York at one time let me say
that I think one of the unfortunate
things that has happened to American
politics was the emergence of these
little 30-second paid ads on television
television is a marvelous instrument the
education and pleasure and the
enlightenment of the American people I
don't know that I ever could have been
elected to office in South Dakota
without television in an essentially a
Republican state but I I would have to
say I'm worried about the reducing of
campaign dialog the kind of thing that
mr. Buckley and I've been doing here
today under rather relaxed and an open
circumstances two little 30-second sound
bites I wouldn't worry about that so
much if it weren't for the drift towards
almost pure negative advertising and
those that you can say positive things
in 30 seconds about what you want to do
to the public
but you can also say mean nasty things
about your opponent and regrettably
those are the things that seem to stick
in people's minds too many cases we've
had good people in this country defeated
by negative advertising thoughtful
people who were trying to serve the
public interest whose images are warped
and distorted by these massive TV
campaigns largely in the 30-second and
60-second spots if you'll pardon a
personal reference I think I was one of
the victims of that type of thing back
in 1972 that's not the only reason I
lost perhaps no one could have won
against an incumbent president is
entrenched as President Nixon but if you
go back and look at the blizzard
of negative campaign spots that were
directed against me in that campaign
with enormous sums of money you might be
puzzled as to how I got any votes in 72
I scarcely recognize myself from that
incessant distorting campaign so I I've
been against that tactic I don't know
what you can do about it other than to
encourage more of the kind of open and
free-flowing debate that mr. Buckley and
I have been privileged to participate in
here today
the answer is of course nothing you can
do about it because up with New York
Times versus Sullivan which is what 32
years old you can't sue unless you can
prove actual malice and the in a
political campaigns almost impossible to
do so some eight years before senator
McGovern ran a Goldwater was paraded as
a person who would intentionally and
delightedly begin a nuclear war so that
the only the only way to get any
historical perspective on it is for
instance go back a few years study what
was said in the Jefferson Adams campaign
it makes it sound absolutely a feat by
contrast in terms of reforms it is I
think terribly important to accept the
postulates the postures are number one
we're not going to repeal the First
Amendment if another repeal first
amendment then people roughly speaking
free to say what they want about each
other
number two there is a no way in which
you can in fact repeal the right of
people to spend what they want to spend
to promote their ideas Buckley versus
Valeo named after my brother a Supreme
Court decision said that you can't
repeal the First Amendment the First
Amendment allows you to spend what you
want they're the best they could do was
attempt to say well it can't the money
must be spent on behalf of ideas it must
not be put at the disposal of a single
candidate blah blah blah the answer is
since 1976 when that law was passed
there's been the soaring increase the
only way to handle it is to have zero
restrictions but require instantaneous
accountability put it all on internet
within 24 hours find out who is giving
of what and that the American people
simply make a
was based on that beginning now is
simply phony restrictions they don't
work and rising costs
I was certainly joined George McGovern
happily in any idea of a board unethical
board that attunes itself to flagrant
violations of civil discourse at least
attempting to wring down on malefactors
the kind of sensor with which they
should be disciplined
our final question will come from dr.
Alberto Dugan chairperson of the
Department of history here at southeast
well let's say which of the thousands of
questions that have come up this morning
should I ask I would like to welcome you
to our campus and I guess considering
the tone of the morning and the notion
of well liberalism and conservatism
lasting the 21st century you speak a
little louder please my question for you
is what do you believe will be the major
political issues that will be carried
into the 21st century and what part will
the liberal through the Conservatives
play regard to each of those issues I'm
glad you asked me that because about the
15 years ago I found myself moderating
an exchange on what would be the big
issues 20 years now and one of the
participants was the futurologist
future or no futurist futurist yeah
futurist of the Economist magazine who
reminded the audience that Walter Paget
the founder of economists had decreed
that every 10 years The Economist should
have an entire issue devoted to what
were the principal predictable problems
of the next 10 years and he was
deputized as the futurist
in charge of this enterprise and had
spent the month before this particular
meeting going back on issues of the
economist dating back to 1850 that the
only thing you could say reliably about
all of them is they were all wrong ie
nobody in the Economist ever predicted
what would be the crowning problem 10
years or hence the problems that I've
heard in my lifetime were that we would
all be consumed in a nuclear war that we
run out of geographical space for people
to live in that there would be massive
permanent unemployment what what in fact
have been the problems they haven't been
exactly those nobody predicted the
problem of wild wild
legitimacy back in 1960 any suggestion
that it was a correlation of poverty is
absolutely incorrect the the back when
the when the blacks were poor before way
back before the civil rights legislation
the legitimacy rate was on the order of
four five percent is now 63 percent
among whites has risen as a percentage
more from six to eighteen percent three
three hundred percent now I'd like to
think that ten years from now that won't
be a problem but I can't persuade myself
I really think it's going to be great
problems with this assembly of the
American family the deconstruction of
the American family is the great problem
of the future now you say what can
conserve this bring to that I invited my
column everybody what view as to what
ought to be done about the single parent
or families to contribute their views
and I had four hundred and fifty dollars
that's a lot and I went over very very
carefully answers people don't know what
to do but they do do believe that at
least the majority Bluff be that they
ought to be they ought to be a mobilized
sense of right and wrong in situations
like this these seventeen-year-old
eight-year-old boy who father's a child
without any intention of paying any
attention to if for the rest of that
child's life is committing a very grave
offense offense against the mother
against the child and
it's
it is one thing to say well we don't
want to go back to the days of The
Scarlet Letter well no we don't want on
the other hand let's acknowledge that
the Scott letter establish something
people didn't want to be publicly
identified as the father of a mother of
a child out of wedlock newspaper estate
flirts with ways to reduce divorce rate
this strict dad so and so so and so
Michigan believes that too many divorces
16th every hundred marriages that's
going in the wrong direction but that's
one step very far removed from creating
a children without any sense of
responsibility for what it is that
you're doing and as I say how to what
extent is a detectable activity that
however tangential bears on the problem
what we're not allowed to we're not
allowed to hang the Ten Commandments in
the public school some dizzy fanatic
believes that that's are more important
than to hang the Ten Commandments and
refer to them and appoint to the moral
responsibilities in implicit that were a
part of revelation four thousand years
four thousand years ago so I would say
that that is the apps that that is a
problem we have right now that's
absolutely palpable yes you can say in
the year 201 to China extrapolated will
have a defensive and offensive force
equal to our own I won't be around those
of you who all will simply have to taste
that problem when it comes I hope it's
not faced by a population that's 90%
born to a single parent
you want me to comment briefly I think
they're in addition to the issues that
mr. Buckley is mentioned I think they're
a a few things I'd like to just quickly
mention we haven't talked much about the
environment here today but this physical
universe that we've been given by
Providence is a very precious treasure
and I think that that's an issue that
has to be near the top of the list of
the 21st century how we protect the
waterways the oceans the forests the
land the air and the other things that
sustain life on this planet I've already
mentioned the health care problem and
that has to be close to the top I would
wager that on any survey and depth
that's a concern that's still very
profound with the American people on the
welfare issue I don't think we've
resolved it simply by ending the welfare
rolls I think that wherever people on
those welfare rolls are either
unqualified or unable to find jobs they
have to be trained and if they can't
find jobs in the private sector then
we've got to come up with useful things
they can do in the public sector and if
we're going to take these young mothers
out of the home and require them to work
in jobs outside of the house then we've
got to provide adequate to day care to
the children at home
incidentally if you want to make some of
those young mothers furious just suggest
that they're doing nothing now it's not
easy to raise a batch of little kids
particularly on a miserable house in a
bad neighborhood and with no man around
so they're they're already burdened but
if we want them to get out of those
circumstances and work outside the home
somebody has to look after the children
there's another issue that has come to
my attention I just want to mention it
in passing it's the issue of alcoholism
and other drug addictions in this
country there are of course other drug
addictions but alcoholism is far and
away the most widespread and the most
destructive we really need to do more
about that problem there's still at
least in my mind more questions than
there are answers about why nearly 20
million Americans are addicted to
alcohol most of us can take a drink or
two without any problem but there are
about 10% of Americans who can't drink
at all without going all the way into
blackouts and collapses and and all the
rest we need to know more about how to
prevent that and how to treat it
one comment on global security that mr.
Buckley has properly identified here
today I think that for 40 years the
United Nations was at least quasi
paralyzed by the Cold War the standoff
between Moscow and Washington and which
they repeatedly tied up the machinery of
the UN because of differing views now
they tend to vote together in the UN and
I think for the first time we have an
opportunity to beef up that organization
it might begin with us paying our dues
and
it needs American leadership and
American strength to turn it into the
kind of peacekeeping and peacemaking
instrumentality that the founders
intended we also need to strengthen the
world court I don't want to see the
United States attempt to be the world's
policemen all by ourselves we have an
important role to play but we have
neither the mission nor the capability
to settle all these trouble spots around
the globe this calls for stronger and
more responsible action on the part of
the United Nations and the World Court
those are issues on which I think
liberalism is perhaps better positioned
to take us into the 21st century than
conservatism
well I've been asked by the Chairman to
reduce my rebuttal to just a sentence of
two I I do feel obliged to make the
following point about my hero Ronald
Reagan which is that the V it is quite
true that the national debt went haywire
but it's also true that he reduced the
deficit he reduced the rate of which the
deficit was accumulating to 70% of the
rate during the preceding 15 years he
also liberated during that period
through tax reductions to be sure
reductions that had been initiated in
1978 and before that reductions that had
been initiated at the promptings of not
Eisenhower not Nixon but LBJ and and
Kennedy he teases me about being in
favor of courting liberals in certain
circumstances the difference between us
is that I quote liberals when they do
good things and he quotes him when they
do bad things Woodrow Wilson's statement
about defining liberalism the history of
man's efforts was saying the government
was written in 1881 in his book
congressional government a book which he
pretty much deplored when we came
president of the United States and
started to have to find out what fun it
was to tell people what to do I thank
you so much for your hospitality I thank
Senator McGovern for his a friendship I
had admire his constancy I thank the
panel and the Chairman and join in the
congratulations to president iski
this concludes our debate both senator
McGovern and mr. Buckley have an
airplane to catch momentarily we hope
you have been joyed the exploration with
us this morning we hope you can attend
the inaugural ceremonies this afternoon
at 2 o'clock and the show-me Center for
those of you who are present who are
involved with the luncheon and
processional there will be shuttle buses
behind academic hall here which will
take you to the recreation and show-me
centers thank you very much for coming
American perspectives continues in a
minute with columnist Suzanne fields
talking about the impact of feminism on
America every Saturday night American
perspectives brings you a look at the
cultural and historical side of US
politics next Saturday at